my next guess is the first comedian from
Finland to perform on American
television this is a first he can be
seen live at the Hollywood Laugh Factory
this weekend and at the improv in Brad
California on February 13th making his
late night stand-up debut with us this
evening please welcome their very funny
is Moe
[Applause]
hello hello good evening I am a Schmo
and yes I am from Finland I moved to
America about a year ago and I need to
be great but I have to say that it took
a long time to learn the things like the
small subtle things like it took me a
year to figure out that the correct
answer to what up is what's up it took a
long time but now I know if somebody
says what's up I just say what job if it
feels wrong like I feel I'm not
answering a question but they are happy
so I just keep doing it and it took me
even longer than that to finally learn
that can I help you actually means go
away
and always murder but like but I think
the language still has been the most
difficult part because I studied English
for years and I thought I know English
but then I moved to America
turns out no like I didn't really know
it like all the things like I think the
hardest word to truly master has been
the word ass I thought it really is it
means a but but no like like year
sometimes it come in a but but that's
just the tip of the iceberg like there
are so many meanings of the word ass I
think it's the most complicated word in
English I've been trying to write a
whole dictionary about just as they saw
me like for example lazy ass
that means lazy like my lazy-ass husband
it's the same sentence without the ass
yes yes it's just optional there it's
and long ass means long like a long-ass
flight long flight but if you want to
make it longer you can add ass and my
definite favorite one a grown-ass man
it turns out it means a grown man the
entire man has grown not only his ass so
so I learned that you can just you can
just add ash to anything and then it
sounds a little bit cooler like anything
I just bought this blue ass shirt thank
you that was some good ass meatballs
anything but but you have to be careful
because sometimes if you add ass to
something it can actually reverse the
meaning of the original word like for
example bad that's good a bad is bad but
badass it's good but not always like
dumb ass is still dumb so how can do you
know you have to know specifically which
ones are flips and and then there's the
concept of your ass and your ass that
means like yourself like like move your
ass that's like move everything move
your ass and the rest of your body and
like everything if you have a car that's
included in the ass
all of them same direction just move so
your ass means yourself plus all you
have but my ass my ass that means like
no like if I say that Wow this car is
really fast and you say oh fast my ass
so it means like no it's not fast and to
make it even more complicated as can be
divided like if you are an ass that
means that you're being stupid but if
you're half-ass it it means that the it
means that you are not concentrating
properly and if you go even smaller if
you are a piece of ass then you are
beautiful
[Applause]
now to get some first composure
you